ae aprendam comigo é este é nosso álbum
faz mais
olha só olha só olha no que deu à dança
nosso jeitinho votar em quem tem
dinheiro pra abrir a copa que pouca
coisa saiu o meu gol
embora daqui
o la coruna fui preso e olha só esse
vídeo tabu e r 1 mil o quilo não comeu
essa porta faz muitas parece um leão
africano que os quanto mais pequenos
mais rápido são tão difícil como é que
ela não conseguiu muito boa essa obra
[Música]
agora vamos pessoal vocês me perguntam
se eu responder isto custa 500 contos
que eu vou aceitar
[Música]
se fosse uma força aí por pobre vai vai
entrou sogros olímpico porque agora não
está fechada há há há
está tudo bem daquele estado com michel
mulheres e sempre vou ter que me chamam
pra mim o meu rosto do meu amigo posso
estar em algum dia rolar para os
expulsar ninguém eu vou segurar o jogo
sofia sofia não não
[Música]
ran blake objetivo checar ainda
transmitir tudo em favor do gigante ela
tava tentarem tomar nem é uma pessoa
aqui dentro aí não pode ser
ela vai trancar destaque uma festa muito
intensa não vai ter um objeto de
campanha da [ __ ] com um objeto amarelo
por isso sua porta
desculpe o botafogo nem dar bem agora
mil
[Música]
ai eu cozinho fechou
ah nem nas horas eles a pessoa tem que
mostrar meus olhos disse lucílio a meu
deus meu não é
vocês viram agora andar a trave
imaginam jogo não não jogo no jogo
[Música]
deixando por um homem
tudo é possível que o bom e velho chocó
ai eu nunca vi uma saia vai comer o que
vai fazer
[Música]